voyez ma main là c'est ma fille et nous
allons chanter ensemble dit papa tu veux
bien chérie
[Musique]
allons-ytit papa oui connais-tu quoi
donc le bon Dieu le bon Dieu réponds-moi
ou répond-moi moi dis
papa dis papa oui ma fille là tu V le
bon Dieu le bon Dieu rpond-moi rpond-moi
dis papa je t'adore mais oui ma
chérie je le connais il est en noué dans
tout en un mot il est
partout mais oui ma chérie
oui je l'ai vu dans pierre du chemin
dans la rose de ton jardin
ah bon dis papa oui connais-tu quoi donc
le Jésus ma poupoune réponds-moi oui
réponds-moi dis papa oui ma fille oui
dis papa làastu vu le Jésus oui oui j'ai
compris
réponds-moi
réponds-moi dis
papa mais oui ma
chérie je le connais il revient au cours
des temps changer le cœur des méchants
mais oui ma chérie oui je l'ai vu dans
le pauvre qui a faim à qui je donne un
peu de
pain ah bon dis papa quoi encore
connais-tu oui Saint-Esprit
Aï AE a a réponds-moi
réponds-moi papa oui oui oui oui dis
papa là tu V Saint-Esprit Saint-Esprit
oui
répond-moi répond-moi dis papa je
t'adore mais oui ma
chérie je le connais car il est le feu
secret qui brûle à nous à
jamais mais oui ma
oui je l'ai vu dans les yeux de braves
gens et dans l'amour de ta
maman oh merci mon papa j'ai compris ah
tu as compris nous trois on fait le
paradis grâce à Dieu c'est bien vrai ma
chérie ta maman ton papa avec toi tu
vois
c'est la
[Musique]
vie allez viens viens il est trop tard
viens te coucher
viens mer